[Música]
tras romper alianzas con los partidos
tradicionales el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro reforma su gabinete
ministerial y cambia a 8 altos
funcionarios el mandatario afirmó que
busca superar las divisiones que
bloqueaban reformas como la de la salud
en Perú el gobierno de la presidenta
dinavoluarte decretó el estado de
emergencia en los departamentos
fronterizos del país la mandataria
aseguró que con la medida se busca
controlar el orden interno y la entrada
de extranjeros al país a quienes culpó
del aumento de la violencia en
territorio peruano
la mayoría republicana en la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos aprobó
ampliar el techo de la deuda pero puso
como condición un recorte drástico del
gasto público algo que rechaza la Casa
Blanca se cree que los demócratas voten
en contra de la ley
Bienvenidos a una nueva informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos el Informativo
en Colombia el presidente Gustavo Petro
pidió la renuncia protocolaria a su
gabinete de ministros para hacer una
recomposición del mismo provocando
tensión en diferentes sectores
principalmente entre los partidos que
conforman la coalición de gobierno el
mandatario colombiano anunció cambios en
los titulares de las carteras de
Hacienda interior salud agricultura
transporte ciencia y tecnologías de la
información y comunicaciones Petro que
comenzó su gobierno con un gabinete
plural ahora se rodea de ministros mucho
más afines a su proyecto político llama
la atención la salida de la ministra de
salud Carolina corcho quien lideraba la
polémica reforma al sistema colombiano
de salud y que deja la cartera en medio
de críticas y señalamientos más temprano
conversamos con Daniela garzón
politóloga
e investigadora de la fundación paz y
Reconciliación pares y le preguntamos si
los recientes fracasos del gobierno de
Petro en llevar a cabo reformas
profundas son las causantes de este
cambio de gabinete el segundo ya en sólo
nueve meses de gobierno
sin duda yo creo que era esperable que
esto pasara en el primer gobierno de
izquierda en Colombia Porque eso
significa Pues que el estatus quo
colombiano es muy difícil de mover y
todo un bloque de orden conservador que
se iba a poner a los cambios que Petro
pues propone desde que está en campaña y
durante toda la trayectoria política que
ha tenido sin embargo yo creo que el
presidente se está jugando el todo por
el todo a tratar de cumplir las promesas
que hizo en campaña hizo también es
loable porque finalmente pues no podemos
caer en un tipo de gatopartidismo de de
cambiar para no cambiar nada Y en este
momento Petro Está tratando de jugar una
estrategia que yo jugó cuando fue
alcalde de Bogotá de la capital de
Colombia y fue un poco tener gente más
cercana que le da un poco mejor lo que
él quiere para el país y tratar de
acelerar la agenda de reformas porque
sin duda la burocracia colombiana y el
estatus quo colombiano hace muy difícil
cambiar algunas cosas Obviamente el
desgaste es notorio y no llevamos ni
siquiera un año de gobierno pero creo
que después de que se agotaron las vidas
de diálogo con los los políticos pues se
piensa un poco más la cuerda con ellos y
finalmente tendrán que decidir si salen
o no de la coalición de gobierno y en
ese sentido Pues el presidente hace
revalidar el hecho de que quien ganó en
las elecciones pasadas fue en Perú el
gobierno de Dina boluarte decretó el
estado de emergencia en todas sus
fronteras con Ecuador Colombia Brasil y
chile para la mandataria Esta es una
medida necesaria que permitirá el
control de las fronteras y actuaciones
policiales y de las fuerzas armadas para
controlar el orden interno en la misma
rueda de prensa aseguró que se
incrementará un control de ciudadanos
extranjeros a los que culpó sin pruebas
ni distinciones del aumento de la
violencia en el país anteriormente
nuestro corresponsal Francisco Zacarías
nos contaba que otras acciones comprende
la medida decretada por boluarte son
siete regiones fronterizas de Perú donde
la presidenta Dina boluarte ha ordenado
ejecutar acciones policiales y militares
con relacionadas al control limítrofe
para preservar el orden la mandataria
peruana señala hoy que para articular
esta medida presentará en breve una un
proyecto de reforma constitucional al
parlamento de este país para autorizar
la presencia de las fuerzas armadas en
las zonas de frontera Dina boluarte
también anunció una ley de homicida por
un plazo de seis meses para exonerar de
multa a los ciudadanos extranjeros en
esta nación andina la medida Busca
beneficiar aquellos ciudadanos
extranjeros que ingresaron con papeles
de manera legal a esta nación y después
por diversos motivos su estatus
migratorio de vino en irregular la
mandataria peruana ha señalado que estas
acciones de urgencias están contemplando
realizar y precisamente se producen días
después que
muchos ciudadanos extranjeros en su
mayoría
migrantes venezolanos quedaron varados
al intentar cruzar desde chile hacia
Perú en esta nación según cifras
oficiales existen más de un millón y
medio de ciudadanos venezolanos y
también existen entre 300 a 400.000
ciudadanos del país llanero que están de
manera irregular Por lo antes señalado
que la medida Busca regularizar las
condiciones migratorias y del mercado
laboral
entre tanto en Bolivia la justicia
amplió por cuatro meses más la detención
preventiva de Luis Fernando Camacho
gobernador de la provincia de Santa Cruz
y líder opositor Los investigadores
hablan de que su papel en las
manifestaciones de 2019 que provocaron
la salida de Evo Morales pudo ser clave
además la fiscalía le imputó una nueva
causa por las protestas del año pasado a
favor del censo Camacho denuncia que la
suya es una detención ilegal con fines
políticos
nos vamos hasta Brasil en donde el
expresidente del país Jair bolsonaro
declaró este miércoles ante la policía
para responder ante los hechos del 8 de
enero bolsonaron negó cualquier
responsabilidad en el ataque a las sedes
de los tres poderes del estado en
Brasilia y explicó a la policía todos
los hechos según indicó la defensa a los
periodistas nuestro periodista Pierre no
se amplía
el expresidente brasileño prestó
declaración durante cerca de dos horas
en la sede de la Policía Federal los
delegados le interrogaron sobre un único
asunto el motivo por el cual fue
convocado un vídeo que compartió en sus
redes sociales dos días después del
ataque a la plaza de los tres poderes
cuyo contenido volvía a cuestionar la
transparencia de las elecciones ganadas
por Lula Los investigadores veían esta
publicación como
indicios bolsonaro incentivó el asalto a
la plaza de los tres poderes a la salida
del interrogatorio uno de sus abogados
declaró la prensa que el expresidente
hizo esa publicación por error en su
página Facebook cuando en realidad
intentaba enviarlo a su WhatsApp para
poder verla después
una torpeza que fue causada según su
defensa por la morfina que él estaba
tomando en un hospital de Orlando cuando
hizo la publicación una explicación que
convence a pocos ya que el perfil
oficial
publicó durante semanas y meses muchos
contenidos falsos sobre las elecciones
antes del ataque del 8 de enero desde su
vuelta de Estados Unidos hace menos de
un mes es la segunda vez que bolsonaro
presta declaración ante la policía
federal la primera fue en otra
investigación sobre el ingreso irregular
al país de joyas muy valiosas regaladas
por Arabia Saudita y en total el
expresidente de extrema derecha enfrenta
decenas de procesos y cuatro
investigaciones en el supremo tribunal
Federal
seguimos en Brasil porque el gabinete de
seguridad institucional de la
presidencia destituyó a 29 funcionarios
un movimiento que se entiende Como una
purga tras los hechos del 8 de enero la
propia presidencia aclaró que
destituyeron a tres de sus cuatro
secretarios nacionales la semana pasada
cambió también el mando del titular de
este organismo al tiempo la Justicia del
país cerró temporalmente el servicio de
mensajería Telegram dado que la empresa
no ha entregado datos requeridos por la
policía y la justicia sobre grupos
neonazis que difunden mensajes de odio y
violencia en esta aplicación
y en Estados Unidos la cámara baja
aprobó la ampliación del límite de
endeudamiento que hoy es de 31,4
billones y que es indispensable para que
el país no entre en The Food en verano
pero condicionada a un recorte drástico
del gasto público esta condición
impuesta por la mayoría republicana en
la cámara ha sido de plano rechazada por
el gobierno de Joe biden se da por
descontado que en el senado esta ley de
tope de endeudamiento segunda ya que la
mayoría es demócrata el recorte de
gastos que ordena el proyecto de los
republicanos es de 4,5 billones de
dólares y el aumento en el techo de
deuda de 1,5 billones
hemos hecho nuestro trabajo me senté con
el presidente del primero de febrero me
ignoró el resto del tiempo está poniendo
la economía de Estados Unidos en peligro
por su falta de acción ahora debes
sentarse a negociar aprobamos esto
temprano estamos en abril muy por
delante del período límite de la deuda
hasta aquí este informativo sigan
conectados
[Música]